a strong handshake is the best way to
start a job interview it's a sign you're
confident competent and ready to swing a
hammer like John Henry on PCP that is if
you're wearing the rowboat glove the
force multiplying hand machine General
Motors wants to use in its factories the
glove is borrowed from Robonaut to a
humanoid bot that GM and nasa sent up to
the International Space Station in 2011
now the automaker is working with
swedish medical company bio servo to
create a glove that'll work just as well
on earth Robonaut can carry 40 pounds in
each hand but it's not all about power
this glove is made to be dexterous as
well it can even make you breakfast sure
the Robo glove looks like it was stolen
from a Power Ranger costume but it's
actually packed with advanced technology
its sensors and actuators are designed
to mimic the nerves and muscles of the
human hand just without the wimpiness
that makes the flesh-and-blood version
all tired after a couple minutes of
heavy lifting GM hasn't said when it
plans on turning its workers into Luke
Skywalker but anybody who's ever gotten
tired spinning a wrench should be
excited about wriggling their fingers
into this steel driving ham